wenchuan you propose voyage sans
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de la première
exploration du nil assistant bertrand
dunoyer montage yvonne ces restes sont
jean charest illustration sonore de nice
laser
voici le monde du pharaon ramsès 2 c'est
l'ère du colossal de l'egypte classiques
déjà des prisonniers comme en attestent
ses fresques
sur la rive droite du nil la falaise et
creusé de nombreux temples et au bout
vous allez assister à quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire
et oui ceci un homme en kayak visitant
un temps
au risque de tuer le rêve je suis
honnêtement obligé de dieu veut ceci est
dû simplement au relèvement d'au créé
par le barrage d'assouan
assoit
son barrage 45 mètres de haut 2 km de
long c'est à lui que l'egypte irrigué
doigt un niveau d'eau constant on
oriente l'eau vers les canaux et aux
morts le plus possible sur les déserts
voilà comment s'augmente la production
agricole d'un pays et ses chais
désertique
tout près de soi une carrière de granit
rose de la ont été extraites les pièces
maîtresses de l'ancienne egypte
la seule différence en procès nubien et
leurs ancêtres c'est que des burins
d'acier
et tout au long de cette partie du nil
des scènes familières calfatage des
felouques je suis en quelque sorte les
péniches du nil mais elles sont belles
car elles se servent du vent
chaque ue
chadoufs procédé d'irrigation antique
louxor c'est l'égypte est classique
celle du touriste temple forêt de
colonne
portique d'entrée
et là regardez bien
là et l obélisque qui se trouve
actuellement chez notre place de la
concorde sont pendants y est encore
les colonnes de memnon garde la plaine
de thèbes
et c'est hors amazon que nous croisons
la statue qui boulet de ramsès ii
voici deir el bahari aux lignes
excessivement moderne et qui cependant
date de trois mille ans les anciens avec
tous les atouts dans leur sac en matière
de proportions architectural nous
n'avons inventé hélas que la ligne béton
armé
la vallée des rois garde des tombeaux
des principaux empereur ayant vécu à
thème avant notre ère bien entendu
le lac sacré au fond les obélisques
monolithe monument d'une seule pierre il
a fallu les lycées jusqu'au ciel sans
les briser probablement par une méthode
de levier mais quel effort
aménophis deux regarde depuis trois
mille trois cents ans en direction du
sud d'où vient le fleuve immense qui a
permis la vie de son empire et de son
peuple
c'est la colonne tarka à l'entrée de la
salle hypostyle
cette salle contiendrait notre dame de
paris à elle seule
le petit temple de schleck la déesse de
la guerre
un
temple d'albâtre reconstitué
et par l'allée des béliers nous
regagnons le fleuve
nous aurons à parcourir 800 kilomètres
jusqu'à delta
c'est l'époque du blé
nous croisons ce bas-relief d'abidos et
ramsès ii coucher à saqqara à saqqara où
se trouve l'ancienne même vise 15
hectares de ruines
et datant de 3500 ans avant jésus-christ
vous allez le voir
les pyramides de jay z et plus vieux
monument du monde
tombeau ornée de fresques représentant
des porteurs de frande
extraordinaire procession
le caire le caire capitale de l'egypte
deux millions d'habitants
c'est la plus grande ville d'afrique
les minarets émergent du fouillis des
maisons
mosquée au conte portion identique à
celle de nos cathédrales elle date du
reste de la même époque
ibn toulouse avec sa cour intérieure
mairie maître ali sur la citadelle
dans ce rituel
le culte des morts a toujours été très
fort en egypte
et les anciens voyait grand tels ces
pyramides qui devait servir du tombeau
sept hommes grimpent la pyramide de
khéops est la plus haute
et enfin le fleuve le fleuve jusqu'à
delta c'est la fin du voyage
tel tas la région la plus peuplée du
monde où règne une misère effroyable
apeurée par cette caméra qu'ils prennent
pour celle d'un quelconque espion ils
iront jusqu'à lancer des pierres à nos
voyageurs dans le but inoffensif leur
paraît impensable
et pour éviter des ennuis plus grave aux
voyageurs cette escorte de policiers
monter leur ai donné
près de recettes ce geste symbolique
presque un geste d'adieu
car il ne reste plus à nos amis capliez
kayak
à serrer quelques mains amies
et a espéré le ciel de vote